so my husband and I always do a holiday staycation
a little date night to get away from the kids
have a little romance and I found the perfect dress on TikTok shop
and I just came in and I tried it on
and it's very affordable which is what I liked because
you know we can't always be spending so much money on the like
the holiday occasion dresses
but what I liked about this
too is it has a very classic silhouette
it cinches you in right here
and then it ties in the back
so the girls are super supported
very important
but I'm just gonna pair it with like
some cute black heels and I feel so glamorous
and maybe with like
a little bit of fur on top to cozy up
this is a perfect holiday dress
I knew when I saw it in the red it was going to be tonight
very old Hollywood I loved it